[Music]
in this video we will discuss the dorsal
column medial meniscal pathway the
dorsal column pathway is a tract of
nerve fibers which is present in the
posterior part of the spinal cord these
no fibers carry sensory information from
all over the body to the brain and this
strut is composed of large myelinated
nerve fibers which carry impulses at a
velocities of about 40 to 110 meters per
second now let us understand what type
of sensory information does the dorsal
column pathway transmit the first and
most important are the touch sensations
especially the fine touch and there are
certain properties of touch sensations
that are only present due to spatial
organization of the nerve fibers in the
dorsal column pathway one of them is
your ability to differentiate where on
the body is a point touching you this is
known as the localization of the touch
sensations the second important property
is your ability to differentiate between
a crude touch and a fine touch and this
is known as the gradation of the touch
sensations other type of sensory
information the dorsal column transmits
are the sensations of vibration and
proprioception all the sensations are
first perceived by specialized receptors
present in the skin known as the
pacinian corpuscles and also the
meissner's corpuscles these receptors
then transmit the information to the
nerve fibers to the spinal cord let's
have a brief overview about the anatomy
of this pathway this is a cross section
of the spinal cord showing the white
matter the central butterfly-shaped gray
matter the nerve roots which enter the
spinal cord posteriorly are known as the
dorsal roots and the ganglions of these
roots are the dorsal root ganglion the
ganglion is a collection of cell bodies
of neurons looking at the cross section
spinal cord closer we can see the green
areas highlighted here are the position
of the dorsal column pathway in the
spinal cord so this is a cell body of a
neuron in the
dorsal root ganglion and these neurons
are known as the pseudo unipolar neurons
because they're one process splits into
two processes the peripheral process
innovates the receptors which has
discussed and carries the sensory
information to the spinal cord through
its central process the central process
where enters the spinal cord divides
immediately into a medial branch and a
lateral branch the medial branch then
ascends upwards into the spinal cord as
the dorsal column pathway the lateral
branch forms multiple synaptic
connections in the intermediate as well
as the interior portions of the spinal
cord these synaptic connections are very
important as the help information of
local reflex pathways some of these
fibers also relay into the
spinocerebellar tracks and some fibers
ascend upwards in the dorsal column
pathway one important thing I would like
here to mention is that the nerve fibers
which carry the sensory information from
the lower part of the body are more
medially located in the dorsal column
pathway and these are known as the
gristle fasciculus and the fibers which
guide information from the upper part of
the body are more laterally located and
known as CUNY at fasciculus let's look
at the organization of the dorsal column
pathway what you see right here are the
multiple cross sections of spinal cord
at various levels from the lumbar spinal
cord up to the midbrain and finally we
have a section showing the cerebral and
the thalamus so we have the sensory
fibers which bring the information from
the lower part of the body enter the
spinal cord as a level of lumbar
vertebrae these fibers directly ascend
upwards till the lower medulla on the
same side of the spinal cord in a
similar fashion the nerve fibers which
bring the sensory information from the
upper part of the body enter the spinal
cord at the level of thoracic vertebrae
and ascend up to the lower medulla these
are the first order neurons in lower
medulla we see two sensory nuclei the
nucleus gray Silas and nucleus curators
in which these tracts relay the nuclei
give rise to second order neurons which
cross to the opposite side of the
medulla
and travel upwards till the thalamus on
the opposite side of the spinal cord
this is known as the decussation
of fibers and these are known as the
internal are white fibers in a similar
way the fibers from the nucleus curators
ascend up till the thalamus on the
opposite side of the spinal cord the
tract which is formed on the opposite
side of the spinal cord is known as the
medial lemniscus
in the midbrain the medial lemniscus is
joined by fibers coming from the fifth
cranial nerve the trigeminal nerve these
fibers bring sensory information from
the head and the neck regions in the
thalamus these second-order neurons
relay in the ventral basal complex and
from here the third-order neurons arise
which project into multiple areas of the
cerebral cortex main lead somatosensory
area one also known as the post central
gyrus and also the somatosensory area -
which is known as the lateral parietal
cortex so this was a brief overview
about the dorsal column medial meniscal
pathway I hope you find this video
helpful thank you so much for watching
this video
like our channel on YouTube for all the
upcoming videos and make sure to LIKE
our channel on Facebook for flashcards
and upcoming notifications